when a box office smashing blogbuster
gets a follow-up flick that breaks the
mold film lovers everywhere Rejoice so
if you're a movie lover yourself you'll
want to keep an eye out for these movies
that got the successful sequel treatment
not once but three times in the 1980s
buddy cot movies are as common as comic
book movies have become today and while
the theme of hardened officers solving a
crime or navigating their platonic
relationship was repeated many times
including in Beverly Hills cup Dragnet
and Tango and cash one franchise
perfected the sub genre Lethal Weapon
starring Mel Gibson Danny Glover and
their formidable onscreen chemistry the
first Lethal Weapon film released in
1987 quickly became the quintessential
buddy cop movie featuring humor action
aist movie stars and the famous line I'm
too old for this the first movie is
considered one of the best action movies
of the era unsurprisingly the magic was
recreated 2 years later with Lethal
Weapon 2 becoming one of the top
grossing movies released leas in a year
that featured celebrated sequels like
Ghostbusters 2 Back to the Future 2 and
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
Gibson and Glover continued their on and
offscreen friendship completing four
Lethal Weapon movies by 1998 while the
actors are retired from their roles the
franchise continued in a television
series from 2016 to
2019 when the Matrix was released in
1999 it was one of the most
groundbreaking and thought-provoking
films ever made left as a standalone the
movie was still be recognized for its
originality and technological
breakthroughs of course what would be
the fun in that created by the wowski
there was such a push for a Matrix
trilogy that the next two installments
were developed together and both were
released in 2003 with bold Concepts and
a fully fleshed out story it seemed for
the longest time that the Matrix would
remain a Trilogy Lily wowski even
referred to the idea of a fourth movie
as a particularly repelling idea in an
interview at the Times Colonist in 2015
however with interest from Star keano
Reeves and Hugo weaving The Matrix
inevitably returned in 2021 capping off
the quadrilogy The Matrix resurrections
brought back much of the same magic of
the original films and did moderately
well at the box office as it stands now
the Matrix will remain a four-part
series in an interview with
comicbook.com producer James mctigue
claims that there aren't any sequels in
the works although he notes that the
open ending means the story could still
grow one comic book adaptation
irretrievably changed superhero movies
forever and the resulting quadrilogy
became the test package for what works
and what doesn't when it comes to
bringing our favorite characters to the
big screen 1989's Batman directed by Tim
Burton and starring Michael Keaton as a
Caped Crusader was unlike any superhero
movie previously made the dark and
gritty scenes of Gotham City and a
mature approach to comic book themes
resulted in a formula for the genre
still in use today Burton's 1992
follow-up Batman Returns doubled down on
the edgy tones and Gastly villains
making it a well rooted sequel the time
has come to punish All God's
Children first second third and fourth
part unfortunately when the studio asked
Burton to step away from his thir Batman
movie that he had already began
orchestrating the franchise took a
significant turn Joel Schumaker became
the new Man In Charge having proven
success with previous films such as St
Elmo's Fire And The Lost Boys sadly the
amount of money that could be squeezed
out of the Dark Knight proved too
tempting for the studio that wanted to
make the superhero project more
familyfriendly in an attempt to sell the
most amount of action figures shakers
Batman Forever and Batman and Robin have
since become the target of many jokes
regarding the comic book adaptation
genre still the groundbreaking success
and design of Burton's duy sustain this
series as one of the greatest quadres
ever
made subverting traditional fantasy
tales and blending classic characters
into one brightly colored World shg
feels as comforting and recognizable as
it it does creative and original
starring and endearing o as he navigates
love friendships and responsibility the
Shrek franchise has made a relatable
ogre and icon I'm an ogre you know grab
your torch and
pitchforks doesn't that bother you aside
from the four main installments there
have been spin-offs specials live
performances and a slew of merchandise
featuring the characters from Far Far
Away with Mike Myers voicing the ogre
and Eddie Murphy as a boisterous psychic
dony the original 2001 Shrek film had
parents and children busting their guts
making it an instant animated classic
that is still celebrated today meanwhile
as the best sequels I want to do the
follow-up films from the Shrek catalog
added depth and growth to the fantasy
world and characters with 2010 Shrek
Forever After the quadrilogy was
complete and has since become a defining
franchise for an entire generation
undoubtedly some fans would choose Shrek
as the greatest quadrilogy in movie
history surprisingly out of all of the
film franchises on this list there's
only one that was intentionally planned
as a quadrilogy dividing an established
literary trilogy The Hunger Games movies
had a solid base to develop from making
it arguably the most undiminished story
told over four movies adjacently the
quadrilogy catapulted the career of star
Jennifer Lawrence who has established
herself as one of America's most beloved
celebrities packed with action romance
and a world with clear lines dividing
the rich and the poor Hunger Games
offers a high concept with deep
political undertones making it an
intriguing Story the whole way through
all four movies were released between
2012 and 2015 The Collection is also one
of the highest grossing film franchises
of all time meanwhile The Hunger Games
is set to return with the fifth movie
The Ballad of songbirds and snakes
however it will not take away from the
original quadrilogy since the new film
is set Generations before the events of
the main films plenty of movie
collections focus on Heroes and
champions but rarely does a villain take
Center Stage however bbal Lector has
become a household name and is the main
focus of a four-part series of Thrillers
it was 1991's the Silence of the Lambs
where Anthony Hopkins delivered a
deranged serial killer performance that
helped the film be remembered as one of
the greatest movies ever made ultimately
it was an obvious choice to expand the
lore of the antagonist by adapting
author Thomas Harris's other novels
undoubtedly it was Hopkins performance
as a cannibalistic doctor over three
films that sets the character apart in
an interview with Vanity Fair the Lector
actor said I'm fairly normal most of the
time but I know what scares people I
knew instinctively that I should be
absolutely still all the talk about he's
a monster I thought well go to the
opposite play him nice I think I'll eat
your heart for the prequel Hannibal
Rising the role was passed down to the
late Gaspar uliel who carried the torch
of making the Hannibal collection one of
the most bone chilling quadres you can
watch often noted for introducing the
comic buug superhero movie into popular
culture it is fitting that the man in
blue types was the first such character
to earn a film quadrilogy when Superman
hit theaters in 1978 it was the most
expensive movie made at the time making
it the first big budget superhero film
and laying the groundwork for one of the
most popular genres in the industry
today expanding the Big Blue Boy Scout
story The quadrilogy plus the spin-off
movie Supergirl redefined what
superheroes could do on screen all while
keeping with the standup tones and
themes synonymous with the character a
significant part of the success of
Superman and his three sequels was the
main actor Christopher Reef embodying
the brightly suited hero Reef became the
Man of Steel for an entire generation
mixed in with an ensemble of celebrated
actors and an instantly recognizable
theme song from John Williams the
Superman quadrilogy will always have a
special place in the hearts of comic
book
enthusiasts the first Jaws movie
directed by Steven Spielberg is
recognized as the first summer
blockbuster to this day jws Remains the
seventh highest grossing movie of all
time when adjusted for get price
inflation the groundbreaking film about
a man eating shark reshaped The
theater-going Experience so it makes
sense that the studio would want to
squeeze everything that they could from
the shark infested property you're going
to need a bigger boat three more Jaws
films expanded the LW of the ocean's
most dangerous animal with new
characters locations and situations the
ground laid by the franchise has
resulted in an influx of shark themed
movies that continue to be released
today with the water Beast appearing in
lowbudget projects almost annually
understandably the multiple Jaws sequels
struggled to achieve the same Acclaim of
Spielberg's project however even the
worst Jaws movies are found an audience
as C Classics meanwhile the franchise as
a whole remains one of the highest
grossing horror franchises of all time
when Toy Story debuted in theaters in
1995 it was a groundbreaking achievement
the completely computer animated feature
was the first of its kind breaking away
from traditional 2D animation equally
Toy Story was the first film produced by
pixer which has become one of the most
dominant Studios when it comes to
animated films the story of Woody buz
and all of their toy friends has created
a legacy that is still prominent today
with the spin-off film Lightyear being
released in 2022 and Toy Story 5 in the
early stages of development an entire
generation grew up watching the diverse
collection of animated toys Bond and
grow over 25 years audiences kept a soft
spot for the iconic franchise akin to
how the human boy Andy treated his
beloved toys spanning from 1995 to 2019
Pixar's headlining franchise has grown
to become one of the highest grossing
animated franchises of all time all
while achieving High Praise from critics
and audiences along the way there is no
doubt the Toy Story quadrilogy is one of
the most successful four-part
collections ever
made
[Music]
Avengers Assemble it would be impossible
to discuss four film collections today
without touching on The Avengers the
Marvel Cinematic universe is built
around the over-the-top Blockbuster
movies that bring all of its most
popular characters together since Robert
Downey Jr arrived as Iron Man in 2008
every Marvel movie has been unabashedly
driven toward an Avengers epic phase one
builds its way to bring together these
heroes in the original Avengers
installment quickly becoming the first
in the MCU to break the1 billion Mark
The Avengers has grown from what could
now be considered a humble superhero
movie in 2012 with the expansion of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and its stable
of character
fans returned to the Avengers movies to
see all of their favorite Heroes face
earth's greatest threats Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers endgame easily
became one of the most Monumental
cinematic events of Our Generation so
while audiences patiently await New
Avengers movies The four-part Collection
as it stands today is one of the most
epic quadres ever
made finally we wouldn't be talking
about film quadres with the alien
franchise used in the film collection's
marketing for a 2003 box set of DVDs and
alien first used the term quadrilogy for
four movie sets and is surprisingly the
only property to do so the movies follow
Ellen Ripley portrayed by sagoni Weaver
as she fights off a dangerous alien
species known as the xenomorph the most
interesting part of the series is each
movie features a different director and
therefore carries a different feel and
tone making each installment a fan
favorite depending on who you ask there
have been many films that have expanded
the law of the xenomorph including two
Alien versus Predator movies Prometheus
and alien
additionally a new alien film was
planned for 2024 but it's rumored to not
continue the story set in the first four
films from humble beginnings as a space-
themed horror film Alien has become one
of the biggest franchises in the world
it is not out the question to call alien
the greatest film quadrilogy of all
[Music]
time